you did something recently that it
shocked me you shot something for shark
week
oh and i can't believe this i i have not
seen it yet
but i'm told that you swam with sharks
which sounds insane to me
you don't fear sharks conan
in the aquatic do you want me to shut
the [ __ ] up is that what you want shut
the [ __ ]
i up you know what bugs me when you
doubt me when you start doubting me
you had the smug face i didn't
you started down i don't think i was
being smug you smug you're a smuggler
you're a smuggler
you smug the [ __ ] out of me
i was concerned andy be real now well i
just think he lives in fear
yes so thank you yeah yeah
you're you're right you're you're
swimming with sharks you weren't scared
at all
no i was not you know what i'll tell you
this much i am a big part of the aquatic
world you understand
and i've been that i've been there for
years what are you my scene you're about
every
oceanographer you're a big part of the
aquatic world what do you
what are you talking about i'm commonly
known uh to all species
of underwater creatures as the black
dolphin
you're the black dolphin i've been to
black
see there you go again that's specific
i am simply looking for clarification
you sir are the black dolphins i am the
black dolphin okay and
see when i go underwater this was like
me
returning to my roots you understand
right
it's me returning to my roots okay um
you know it's as if it's that this
didn't happen but it's as if
i was birthed and you know how you you
see movies where they put a baby in a
little basket
and they and they sent them down a river
and then some other family found some
finds the baby in the basket oh my baby
in a basket and raised that child
yeah i was put in a boat a little
inflatable boat put in the ocean
and i floated through the ocean it was
found by some
friendly very nice dolphins and they
raised me
as the black dolphins you're the black
dolphin no
being i'll tell you something man it is
the most amazing feeling in the world
to be under water and and all you hear
coming i'm telling you all you hear is
your breathing
it's the most amazing feeling in the
world you know and when i get to space
don't know what i say when i get to
space i'm going to say this [ __ ]
feel like the ocean
that's what i'm saying same thing same
thing
yeah and now we'll tell you one thing oh
the convenience of it all
cause who has time to keep going back up
to that boat
to take a piss who has time
while you're underwater just let it go
i don't i don't think here i don't think
you're the first one
yeah yeah no it's amazing i understand
it's an amazing feeling
knowing you can piss on yourself and
there's no repercussions
there's no stain there's no stain so you
want to your dream is to piss urinate on
yourself with no repercussions
oh man i was underwater man you have
strange
aspirations look when i'm underwater and
my flippers are moving like this
hey look i'm like this
that's how you move okay wait a minute
man
so do you do you i mean jb are you
wearing that
hat when you're underwater you just give
you know and
and i gotta i gotta show love to the
sharks man cause
they showed me love you know they didn't
have to do that you know a dolphin shows
up
you know at this at this [ __ ] reef a
dolphin just shows up out of nowhere
you know they showed so much respect for
the black dolphin
yeah and i know i i appreciate that yeah
and wait right now i just want to give a
big shout out out there to my people out
there
you know who you are the reef shark the
tiger shark
sand shark much appreciation goes out to
you
you show me love like that you show me
mad love
no but i tell you man it is a if you
haven't done it yet if anyone has
anybody ever done it before
it is the most before i'm telling you
before you jump
in you are terrified yeah but for some
reason there
is this calm these sharks were swimming
around
myself and brad paisley we we did we
you know we did it well i mean i don't
even think you needed to say that yeah
no we
all we the black dolphin hangs out with
brad paisley of course he does
of course he does yeah have you ever
paisley's probably the white girl
yeah see here's my thing here's my thing
you know i know who i am i communicate
with these animals i go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's dolphin court yeah that's dolphin
talk so
so so see you you have to like i know in
the black dolphin
who are you
in this in this beautiful world of
underwater world well you tell me you're
the expert what
what underwater uh creature am i i got
them i got them all ready okay well you
are
what you're a red snapper
come on man come on man red snapper
got see now here's the difference
between me and you yeah i can i can
thrive
under under the water yeah amongst the
sharks yeah and the sperm whales and the
blue whales
you see i can live down there because
they understand me they accept me
into their circles but you you're a red
snapper
you gonna end up on somebody's [ __ ]
plate
right solder mash
mash guess what guess what i'll be we're
gonna bring this full circle i'll be the
special yeah i'll be
you're the special